le gouvernement fédéral ajoute 10
millions de dollars à son fonds des
infrastructures alimentaires locales
pour financer des petits projets
communautaires dans l'ensemble du pays
la ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire marie-claude hypocrite
avec nous pour en parler bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est quoi le genre de projets
visés par cet appel de propositions vous
lancez aujourd'hui qui peut profiter des
sommes disponibles dans ce fonds alors
le fonds des infrastructures alimentaire
le cas le découle de notre première
politique alimentaire pour le canada ce
sont principalement les banques
alimentaires les cuisines collectives
les maisons des jeunes par exemple ont
des organisations sans but lucratif pour
la plupart qui ont des projets d
infrastructures des équipements qui leur
permettent de soi nourrir la population
dans la communauté mais aussi les aider
à apprendre comment cuisiner alors faire
découvrir aussi la possibilité de
produire leurs propres légumes de les
commercialiser à tout ce qui touche le
renforcement de notre système
alimentaire dans nos petites communautés
et des petites communautés inclus à
montréal oui parce que l'annoncent avait
lieu ici mais évidemment l'offre en fait
le fond que vous lancez c'est accessible
hors montréal également madame les beaux
absolument autant en ville par exemple
ce matin j'étais à la cuisine cuisine
collective hochelaga maisonneuve qui a
reçu du deuxième appel de propositions
une enveloppe de 230 5000 $ et lorsque
j'ai annoncé ce matin si on lance un
troisième appel de propositions
pourraient des six organisations
que ce soit en ville ou en région parce
que les besoins sont toujours grandmont
évidemment avec la pandémie on a
l'impression que la situation s'était
temporairement en grave et on en est où
là maintenant
huit mois plus tard en ce qui concerne
la situation d'insécurité alimentaire
vous avez raison avec la pandémie on est
passé d'un canadien sur 8 à 1 canadien
sur sept qui avoue nous dit qu'ils ont
trouvés en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire dans la dernière année donc
ça s'est effectivement aggravée c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place des fonds
pour aider directement les banques
alimentaires avec vraiment pour leur
permettre d'ajouter plus de denrées les
distribuer
mais le fonds des infrastructures
alimentaire locale vise à les doter
d'équipements qui vont durer dans le
temps et leur permettre d'être encore
mieux organisés mais installé pour
contribuer dans leur commune au bon
l'équipement c'est bien je suis certaine
que l'aide est la bienvenue mais les
banques alimentaires font face à des
demandes qui ont explosé de 30 à 40 %
depuis un an et demi et des organismes
comme moisson montréal qui disent ne
pouvoir l'heure où la demande va revenir
au niveau où au niveau pré pandémie est
ce que votre gouvernement agit aussi à
ce niveau là absolument donc jusqu'à
maintenant ces 200 millions de dollars
qu'on a distribués à travers les
différents réseaux de banques
alimentaires à travers le pays
4500 organisation en ont bénéficié dans
le budget 2021 c'est une enveloppe
additionnelle de 140 millions de dollars
aussi alors on suit ça de près avec les
grands partenaires comme le réseau des
moissons à travers food banks canada par
exemple les réseaux des petits déjeuners
l'armée du salut donc on a un certain
nombre de grands partenaires qui ont des
réseaux partout à travers le pays
aussi dans les communautés éloignées les
communautés nordiques
bon alors il ya la demande contre
l'insécurité alimentaire et à l'autre
bout de la chaîne vous avez commencé à
parcourir le territoire madame des baux
à la rencontre de producteurs de
transformateurs
quelles sont leurs défilent en ce moment
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous préoccuper
au moment où on tente de relancer
l'économie
évidemment les changements climatiques
les extrêmes climatiques c'est sa
demeure toujours pour les producteurs
agricoles et les productrices un enjeu
majeur mais je dirais que la main
d'oeuvre autant la main d'oeuvre à la
ferme que dans les usines de
transformation que dans nos laboratoires
que ce soit des agronomes
où des scientifiques qui font la
recherche ou encore des gens au niveau
plus techniques au niveau
toutes ces nouvelles technologies le
secteur de l'agriculture et de
l'agroalimentaire beaucoup beaucoup à
offrir donc il faut vraiment encourager
les canadiens qui ont un intérêt des
intérêts très très variées au niveau des
métiers des professions mais on a une
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre assez grave qui
touche plusieurs secteurs dont le
secteur agricole est aujourd'hui en lien
avec la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
justement y avait le conseil du patronat
qui propose des solutions à la crise
demandent entre autres d'assouplir le
programme des travailleurs étrangers
temporaires mais de rendre les
procédures plus rapides plus simple
qu'est ce que vous pourriez vous lui
répondre déjà avec la commune
ça nous obliger à faciliter un certain
nombre de processus de travail est plus
en ligne
qu'on le faisait avant mais je peux vous
assurer qu'avec mes collègues la
ministre de l'emploi et le ministre de
l'immigration
on est en train de revoir justement on
est en train de de chercher d'une façon
de moderniser ce programme des
travailleurs étrangers
évidemment en collaboration avec le
gouvernement du québec et ça va dans la
bonne direction on avance bien dense
dans le sens où nos producteurs
producteurs agricoles l'espère par
exemple de reconnaître les employeurs de
confiance des employeurs qui accueille
des travailleurs d'année en année et qui
sont exemplaires quant à l'accueil qui
leur réserve bon auparavant les
travailleurs temporaires étrangers
madame d'emosson en valais souvent en
majorité dans les champs aujourd'hui les
industries du tourisme et à la
restauration qui vont guider aussi
d'avoir recours à des travailleurs
étrangers pour combler les besoins de
main d'oeuvre est ce que vous craignez
que ça fasse une espèce de concurrence
pour les agriculteurs jeu on en a besoin
je l'entends aussi je l'entends dans les
pme manufacturières dans les secteurs de
la restauration et du tourisme de façon
générale donc je crois qu'il y en a pour
tous les goûts
maintenant il s'agit de faire en sorte
que notre système d'immigration soit
toujours aussi solide et responsable et
on le fait en collaboration avec le
gouvernement du québec évidemment mais
on sera à l'affût de l'issue de ces
discussions d'ailleurs madame bibeau
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là merci à
vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit